all right welcome to a new video um
after quite some break on the subject
them I decided to do a book review on
book recommendation again because well
it doesn't make much sense to me to talk
about books that I don't like so I
recommend the book to you um but it's um
gets only made mostly interesting for
players to play one eform that's already
played here on the board um most of my
opening related stuff in the cello has
been about yeah nany for opening so if I
spoke about one year for that it was
from blacks point of view in my e45
repertoire series so I only talked about
this from black side so um this book
here is about one a form and it's called
beating unusual chest offenses one a
form it's by an international master
Andrew greet and yet this author has
some written a couple of books on before
it's not his first book and I really
like those books so I became interested
in this subject also I mean I don't even
play 1.e4 but there are some trans
positions after one default so because
well I play I play d4 and if someone
goes g6 arm or g6 and then I like to
play your form and it sort of transposes
so this book was interesting also for me
but I also as I mentioned like the other
books that he wrote before you want a
very nice one about the Queen's Indian a
defense for black and also about
what was at the accelerator dragon young
are both fine books so what is this book
about
I think it addresses a pretty important
issue for 1.e4 players and that this is
if you look what what are the most
popular moves um you'll see that if you
add it all up I guess 80% of the time
you get something out of those four
moves at c5 c6 c5 or c6 yeah so both E
and C pawn moves those form on the most
popular bit offenses and I guess this
applies to all levels of chess you very
often see in them in the lower ranks
like 1500 players or something they play
e5 very often because it's the first
move that day that they learn or the
French is very popular on club level but
also on on the International Circuit
so those four moves are basically the
main moves and against these you very
often have a wide choice of what you can
play and usually also cannot well expect
you to get some huge advantage in the
opening because well those moves are
main lines for a reason because now they
they're pretty reliable for black but
you have quite a huge choice as white
against all those defenses let's say
just for just for instance if you if you
look at the French you can easily play
this or not see three or five or
whatever you have a couple of choices
after you five it sets even it's even
more even this position you have Bishop
c4 or Bishop oops this was a bit too
quick here or you have half the reuleaux
path there should be five so White has a
really huge choice and also quite a
choice of styles and how you can handle
those different openings and what greed
did here in this book he compiled a
repertoire for white
against everything but those four moves
so in this book here which has 300 pages
total you get recommendation against all
blacks moves besides II v e6 c6 and c5
so this sum comprises quite a huge um
yeah range of moves but it's very useful
to have one guide where you get get
sound and solid advise against all those
moves because I mean they they they do
they do get played it's not like you
never get the lichen when I look and I
cannot pronounce it I'm sorry
defense or you you get the Scandinavian
or Center counter at one point and he's
got recommendation against all of these
so he basically says okay you need to
have something ready for the big form v5
v6 and so on but it's very much a matter
of taste but I'll show you one way
against those somewhat rarer moves where
you can really fight for an advantage
because these moves are not so 100% on
the same kind of level of soundness that
those other four moves are so I think
you you you have much more yeah what how
to phrase it have much more reason to
hope for something if the opponent plays
like d6 or g6 I mean you you have more
possibilities to press for an advantage
compared to those main lines in a way so
um what so what is in this booklet just
that just to go quickly through this
it's in center counter or Scandinavian
defense the 11 or alicorn defense
it's about all kinds of stuff with d6
followed up by quick e5 or or g6 so the
pro modern defense also the usual puts
defense also those kind of lines this is
all in this book
also attest those moves like v6 or even
those yeah this is this move this move a
six which once was played by Tony moths
to be Karpov yeah which is always yeah
given that some kind of sensational
result of course it was a sensational
result but our months winning with a six
but no one really looks at the game and
Karpov was completely winning and some
are blunder disposition okay so it's
it's all kinds of moves on 96 I forgot
it's also also in this book so at it has
quite a huge range of singer moves here
from next point of view that it handles
I give you a quick overview what he
recommends some so that you get an idea
what kinds of lines is giving let's
start with the the Scandinavian defense
of course it takes and let's look at the
community fire first he has got a quite
an interesting recommendation of course
you would instantly play this move
because well everybody plays it almost
winning a tempo and continuing from here
Queen a five or twenty six are the moves
yeah but he's giving some different idea
and I really like the idea he's they're
recommending in Knight f3 which is
somewhat somewhat rare a move but it has
a very very ambitious idea in fact if
you look at the position with 93 quite
often if you put some kind of normal
position on the board
quite often this knight on c3 is not
particularly well placed it's in this
case even in the pin here so it cannot
move but very often you really want a
pawn on c3 to support the point deform
or even want to advance c4 at some
points also an idea
so this knight on c3 is often not really
a good piece this also shows why I white
very often play something along these
lines here to get rid of the the knight
on c3 so what white tries to do with
Knight f3 is in fact he wants to win a
tempo on the Queen but he wants to do so
using the move C form later he wants to
set up C for D for sort of building up
an ideal Center and he just delays the
the tempo gain here with this move
Knight f3 the drawback of the smooth um
well the the issue is black can play
very actively here Bishop g4 which
should be 296 deform and long castles
and if black doesn't go for long
cancelling setups white can I think
counting at one advantage because he has
some this tempo was C for later and just
has an advantage in the center it's not
completely easy but white should be
better if black doesn't play so
ambitiously and him I think his main
recommendation is this should be three
if I'm not mistaken yeah Bishop b3 and
this leads to quite interesting
complications something along these
lines here
and you see it's um I don't want to rep
yeah to give everything I'm sorry to
give everything what's in the book in
this video it just want to show it it's
quite a sharp line but it's a kind of
line if you if you know you're stuffy
and looked at this in the book you have
quite a good chance to to get a real
advantage in the opening because black
very often doesn't know the details of
this kind of sharp lines and if black
doesn't go for this long castling as I
mentioned um it's very convenient for
white this kind of setup also would
happen if black plays this kind of stuff
then you can just continue Nadia free
and if you go here white will occupy the
center again he also gives some detailed
analysis of this
I think the Schneider 3 idea in in this
kind of at this point here it's very
worthwhile considering because it's it's
less explored and black players don't
know it so well and you have real
chances of surprising your opponent
while still being in need maybe it's a
good line it doesn't have a serious
drawback um also a table has been played
by a couple of top players let's say I'm
of this young sega moves easy on who's
the 2007 700 grand moff so it has been
played back rear shock or Kuryakin so
it's it's not an obscure line that no
display I would would touch so I'm quite
interesting this recommendation against
the Scandinavian um so um the second
chapter here deals with the modern and
the the Piltz defense
so we're talking about the pilk pills
whatever here on the modern this way or
I am where this move order um yeah of
course those two openings are somewhat
related and can easily a transpose um he
has a very straightforward approach as
he basically always wants to go for an F
for setup which I really like I think
this is a very very classical kind of
way to walk classical's maybe not enough
the correct way to put it but a very
straightforward way to play it it
occupies the center and develops your
pieces to to somewhat logical squares
like Knight to f3 later Bishop here here
maybe Queen to d2 or e2 and then
according to circumstances Castle long
or Castle short quite a lot of arrows cm
I think you should get rid of this it'll
be too much so um it's very young very
much focused on central control that
pawns which in my book always makes make
sense so he goes a form here and he also
goes a form in this kind of position and
also yeah and that's also this move all
that like my choose with c6 where he
also goes for f4 with this
as a possible continuation so it's some
quite consistent here this some F form
approach um black and this D six lines
also might go for this set up here also
answered by a form and I think this is
some well-known for a couple of years
that black can't really equalize him
that I mean it would be quite strange if
I can just ignore the center here so um
this is just I think the best line
against c6 he comes up with a surprising
at least for me um recommendation
against f5 the sort of neo awfully Dom
uh most people here trying to fight for
an advantage with the night f3 or maybe
some try nighty to but usually it's one
of those night moves and D takes d5 is
usually not regarded as being too
dangerous but he makes a quite
interesting case form this exchange with
um this being one point this g3 move
it's quite interesting um it prepares
this Bishop exchange with Bishop birth
to age 3 at some point but also her pass
F form which can be a good idea to
attack the center here what might cast
long at a later stage but not right away
it's an interesting idea and maybe quite
poisonous to to try this one reason also
is some why sometimes the study of those
somewhat yeah down looking exchanged
lines can be a interesting is from
blacks point of view he's got quite some
other lines to worry about and not so
much the exchange so very often players
don't really look at this in so much
detail and if you have an idea which is
some interesting that it's maybe you
were to try it's quite similar to two
my own experience with lines like the
Slav exchange for white which is really
it really has a dull reputation of being
sort of unambitious and well well yeah
mom if you look at my score um you'll
see that there were normal saw game so
it's it's just like black is not really
looking at those lines
um because there are other things too to
worry about and if you have some ideas
in there it's maybe maybe interesting to
to try this recommendation but if you
don't like it you might as well choose
some other stuff which you can look at
in another book or in the database like
in IDF 397 and Bishop c4 the main line
or even sheriffs crazy g4 here which is
still not refuted amazingly so
interesting stuff there as well um yeah
I think that's it basically for those
d6g six kind of lines next up is the 11
lakyn mm-hmm Elohim defense where he
chooses the following of course II five
g-46 yeah now why it has some mostly two
choices here long c4 Knight f3 and he
opts for them yeah arguably the main
line with Knight f3 the most solid and
yeah maybe most promising way it's um
it's a bit hard for me to evaluate this
because I'm not a huge expert here um he
he doesn't go for c4 which is the main
alternative I think the four pawns is um
still valid but not the kind of line
white really fights one advantage um
it's very double-edged and I think
against the exchange here he takes these
six is pretty solid for black
it's not yeah it's not the most exciting
line for both sides really it looks a
bit like a Petrov with the open e far
well very often you get pieces exchanged
later so um he goes some form
yeah well Knight f3 here man he looks at
all black some continuations here g6 we
should reform c6 and so on
details e5 is the main line nowadays
followed by the app by g6 or c6 which is
maybe the most common line nowadays also
played my cards and some occasions and
white cannot really hope for a huge
advantage against this opening but it's
often the kind of slide advantage with
some better control of the center
slightly better development those kind
of small advantages that you need to
nurse some long-term with long-term
plans and some maneuvering you cannot
over run like here um I don't think I
need to really go into detail here I
think the general consensus about this
opening the legend or Alec Owen is that
if white knows his stuff he will get a
little bit of something it's not a huge
advantage but it's it's something and
this book um yeah just compiles the the
known information there how to get to
this slide advantage I think it's
nothing spectacular in there but it's a
good compilation of the stuff you need
to know to have something here um I
think um these are the the main the main
points here in the book the other lines
are really quite obscure but you get
them once in a while yeah on knight c6
um replace Knight f3 which is important
in a way so if you get e5 here you
better know what what you do so if you
play oh no the Vienna or something
against you 45 and then um well you need
to have an idea here but okay if you
play the Vienna you might might go here
and yeah that's actually quite quite a
bit of material on this line which I
really didn't know before at all um he
plays Bishop III just normal developing
stuff and usually ends on the slight
advantage for white which is very
believable used to left some some
central advantage um yeah he also gives
a bit of something on b6 here he gives
this line which is quite interesting
with Knight G - I didn't know that
really but that it makes them yeah it
looks oh it looks quite interesting to
to study the idea being on c5 he
sacrificed the pawn here which is a
well-known idea from defaulting so you
don't see it so often in an e-form um
yeah I don't want to look at it in
detail here but it looks like quite
interesting compensation and on a move
like he should be for um this is quite
pointers as it just Nets white the
bishop pair before is very nicely
protected um so um I think it's a pretty
pretty good book it does a good job of
providing you with just the right amount
of information you need to know to to
battle all those slightly less common
lines but they're still not unimportant
I think it's good to have something
ready especially against those
d6 and g6 lines I'm not quite sure about
the statistics here but I think those
are played more often on a club level
than you then you might might think
compared to those yeah big for opening
Searcy 6555 and e6 and it's good to have
some idea ready on on those and some
some off aside yes there are quite quite
poisonous I would say so yeah I made
this book review also for the one you
poor players here because I sort of
neglected this before in the channel so
um yeah who should get this book it's
always difficult to say what kind of
let's say rating range is suited for for
a book I think from 1800 1900 upwards
this book is very very much okay to use
it doesn't really have the the depth of
those some candid from mammoth
Grandmaster repertoire serious books
which are certainly fantastic efforts
but very hard to use for the average
player because they're simply too
detailed some it's just difficult in
those really big big and and thorough
books to find the essential points and I
think it's quite um it's quite a good
effort here to to show those essential
lines so that you can play this here
with confidence um yeah I'll post the
link in the description maybe a slightly
later so that you can have a detailed
look at the book and maybe I'm not quite
sure there's even an extract at the
publishing side so that you can have a
concrete look at at some of the some of
the stuff yeah thanks for watching the
video I also like to hear your for
some about book reviews what kind of
books you would like to see reviewed in
the future maybe um yeah thanks for
watching and talk to you soon with a new
video